what's in a name that which we call a
rose by any other name would smell as
sweet well shakespeare turns out
that ain't true especially when it comes
to baby names
i don't care how cute your baby is the
pressure is on for the perfect
baby name and believe me when i say
everybody you know
has an opinion on your baby's name
heaven forbid you want to name your baby
brad but your sister-in-law once dated
a kid named brad who had rancid cheese
breath
i mean do you really want that
association do you want
baby brad the rancid cheese breath baby
i don't think so believe me when i say
finding
the perfect baby name is not easy
luckily through trial and error and some
pretty
unique techniques i was able to find
the perfect baby name and today i'm
feeling nice
so i'm going to let you in on that
secret this is how you find
the perfect baby name whether you're
looking for a new name
for a baby or yourself you gotta start
with a list but where do you find names
to put on the list
well you can use your memory you can
look at objects around you
crib ice cream those could be names
maybe not good names
but they could be names the most common
places to look are books with baby names
there's a lot of websites listicles the
social security administration has a
bunch of baby names
those are all easy places to find ideas
for names
if you're really interested in a family
name you can look at
old family trees or ancestry.com
to see if there's anything up there that
you hadn't seen before
this is something that my partner and i
did there were some gems
in his family tree the name olga came up
and in mind
the name capitola now we did not end up
going with those names so those names
are free for the taking
you're welcome there are also a lot of
different apps you can use that can help
you find
a name that you and your partner can
agree on you basically both download the
app you swipe right
or left whether you like the name or not
and the names that you both like
will show up on a list so you don't even
have to talk to your partner to find a
baby name
and isn't that the way it should be you
can also ask social media
in my case i asked youtube commenters
and i got some pretty creative ones
i also got a lot of you know what they
didn't have my baby's best interests at
heart let's just say that but say you've
checked those places and you're still
like i'm not finding anything
there are some weirder places you can
look
there's the obituary and i know that
sounds dark
but old-timey names are making a
comeback now
so you would actually be very on trend
and if you're more adventurous
you can actually go to a cemetery i know
again that sounds very dark
but my sister her name actually comes
from my parents going to
a family gravesite and finding her name
okay so here's a cemetery a lot of
different names
we're going to take a look what do you
think of the name gavilan
i think ursula is a cool name arthur
and finally when you're making the list
you might want to honor your cultural
heritage
and there's a lot of different sites you
can look at but you can also just like
go to the wikipedia page of your
hometown and um see
who famous is from there alex azar frank
perdue
if you're into chicken or like i said
that could be a bit of a bust
just an idea okay so now you have your
list to name congrats
okay you're like halfway there but now
the real hard work begins
how do you pick the name from this list
you probably want something that's
unique but not
too unique there's a website called data
eyes that is a baby name uniqueness
analyzer it uses information from the
social security administration
and will tell you like what the chance
your particular baby name has of being
in the same kindergarten class with
somebody of that name that could be
important to you
i had a pretty common name and so i was
looking for a name that was not as
common
i do not like it when someone else has
my name
and my sister-in-law has my name we are
both sarah burton
whether or not you want to find
something super unique it's useful
because
popular baby names have been trending
down and by that i mean a smaller
percentage of babies
are given one of the top 10 names then
would have happened
10 20 30 years ago they're just more
names to pick from
and they're more names being used so my
baby's already gonna have a pretty
unpronounceable last name so it was
important to me that their
unique first name was still largely
phonetic
that it could be pronounced pretty
easily we have a list of names
yeah some of them were from the cemetery
and some of them were from
the name app stuff we both liked and i
think we do have a front runner that
actually showed up
at both places creepily enough but
it's a name with like a lot of different
spellings and so we have to
figure that out it never ends another
thing you have to deal with
is how to spell the name which can
honestly
be as controversial as the name itself
if you're between a few spellings this
is a good rule of thumb
does this name look like it came out of
the canterbury tales
does it look old english are there wise
all over the place
it's 2021 not 1365.
finally probably the biggest way to
narrow down the names is to find out
what your baby's sex at birth will be
um hi my name's sarah burton and i just
missed a call
about test results
i mean for me it helped me stop
referring to my baby as an it which was
nice
although this probably isn't as
effective as it used to be because
unisex and gender neutral names are very
in right now so you think you've zeroed
in
on a particular name now this is where
stuff gets really tricky
it's the hardest part telling other
people the baby's name telling other
people the name is the truest test of
whether your baby name
sucks you can avoid this step by not
telling anybody the baby's name
until the baby is born what are people
gonna look at this cute little
baby and tell the baby that the names
suck are they gonna look at baby brad
and be like oh brad you have a rancid
cheese baby name you stupid baby no
they're not gonna do that you wouldn't
say that to
a baby you would say that to the parents
of the baby so here's what you should do
you want to start slow
introduce the name like give them the
background
how long how hard it was for you to get
to that name
they're not going to jump on you when
they know you've been really struggling
with this decision
all right so i know i talked big game up
top about
how to find the perfect baby name i know
that that's the whole concept of this
video there really isn't just
one perfect baby name there's a lot of
perfect baby names and they're all
different for
each person there are also a lot of bad
baby names and you need to be aware of
those
i'll put them in a list at the end just
don't pick any of those we actually
ended up picking a name based on
that app it was one that we both swiped
right on
and we kept coming back to it we have a
list of names yeah some of them were
from the cemetery
and some of them were from the name app
and i think we do have a front runner
that actually showed up
at both places it's also a name you can
find in several different cultures so
it's largely
pronounceable it's not in the top 100
baby names but it
is in the top 500 baby names my husband
does want to wait for us to tell
everyone the name until the baby is born
so you can't be mean to the
baby face but you know i'm making this
video so i'm obviously going to tell you
the baby's name is going to be
burton round check
[Music]
curtain the baby's name is
the baby's name is
how the hell did he learn to bleep that
[Music]
mother
[Music]
you